hello look at it it's all green it's all
look at this I'm sorry epilepsy warning
um so this video I had some technical
difficulties I had to record it like
three times and bear with me sometimes
it's gonna lag and sometimes this is
going to appear very briefly and I'll
cut the video together so that it's
minimal impact let's dive in I'll fix
the setup next time
hold on to your horses because we have a
new contender in town it uses less GPU
memory it has a higher throughput it has
a lower latency and it scales better
than transformers this is Redneck the
new Chad compare this to measly old
Transformer it's better in every way and
that's what we're going to look at today
retentive networks now is it actually
better in every way uh I guess the
answer is it depends and we'll see and
the jury see it out and yada yada yada
but will keep the tension up so today
we're looking at retention Network a
successor 2 transformer for a large
language models by you Towson Lee Don
and others of Microsoft research and
tingua University so as I said the claim
here in this paper is quite a big one
and
um yeah they say they propose retentive
Network as a foundation architecture for
large language models simultaneously
achieving training parallelism low-cost
inference and good performance
in that yeah let the the experiments are
going to show that retentive networks
are sort of superior to Transformers in
many ways now the experiments in this
paper are quite extensive and this is by
Microsoft research so at least I would
put some weight on what they claim right
here on the other hand I also feel we
haven't seen the end of this yet and
there might be some trade-offs that are
not that evident in the paper so
uh
this paper by the way we've discussed in
our Saturday Discord discussions every
Saturday we have paper discussions it's
evening in Europe time if you're up for
that come by uh give it a try however
this particular discussion I've missed
so I'm very sorry if I say here
something that the group has concluded
to be not true this is just my reading
of the paper I've missed that one
Saturday where we discussed this so
diving in the paper
presents this triangle right here they
say retinet makes the impossible
triangle possible the impossible
triangle being this triangle here of low
cost inference training parallelism and
strong performance low-cost inference
means I can run inference without having
to incur a sort of quadratic explosion
of some resource in this case it's going
to be Memory so if I run inference with
a Transformer which you can see is not
on that side so a Transformer is on this
side of the triangle a Transformer as my
sequence length grows I'm going to need
a quadratic amount of memory in order to
run inference now there are some
trade-offs I can do
um specifically I can trade it off for
time and put that memory on disks and so
on but in some form I'm always going to
pay to run that inference because that
Transformer has attention from every
token to every other token and using
that soft Max on top and that just
inherently makes it expensive on the
other hand we have training parallelism
now you can see Transformer does have
training parallelism which means that I
can train if I have a sequence I can use
that as a training example to not only
train one token prediction but to train
essentially every single token in the
sequence becomes a training example
that's called training parallelism and
you see most notably recurrent networks
over here don't have that so in a
recurrent Network I can only train for
one token at a time and that kind of
hinders them at scaling to really big
big or hinders us to apply lots of
compute to them and getting them to
strong performance even though from the
triangle here you can see at least the
assumption is that if we could scale
recurrent networks they would exhibit
strong performance and I believe there
is some evidence for that although
that's to me a bit Shady
and then the last thing
um no we had we had all a strong
performance is just an experimental
thing so strong performance just means
experiments show that it's strong the
third side here is the linear
Transformers linear Transformers notably
have low cost inference because they
scale linearly and we've seen a number
of them long former and so on they kind
of try to break down that attention
mechanism to make it scale to really
long sequences to not have that
quadratic explosion of memory usage and
training parallelism notably because
they are Transformers they're also be
able to train to be trained in parallel
they say retnette is everything retnette
is in the middle here and
um it achieves all three things now note
that in my opinion retina is sort of in
this category of linear Transformers so
I would denote it something like this
okay retina being in this category of
linear transform now you can also say
it's in the category of recurrent
networks uh but note that the strong
performance that's purely from an
experimental standpoint that's purely
saying them running experiments and
saying well this is actually really good
and it's not the same as low cost
inference and training parallelism these
are architectural features that you know
it's you can you can sort of just see by
looking at the architecture so they
built something that has low cost
inference training parallelism but they
also claim well we have strong
performance so how do they achieve this
um
they achieve this by essentially going
the route of rwkv and building something
that is both a sort of a transformer-ish
model and also a recurrent model
so they down here they explain what they
do maybe first let's just explore this
in essence what this model does what
retina does is it makes everything into
a linear computation and by being linear
they can be both parallel and recurrent
at the same time so let's demonstrate
something like this
why
can a recurrent network not be trained
in parallel so if I have a recurrent
Network I don't know I
saw
a cat right I have this sentence I put
it into a recurrent neural network I
have to process each token into a hidden
State propagate that hidden State
process this token propagate that hidden
State and so on
so if I want to train with this token so
what's this token given all the tokens
to the back I can only only do so by
forward propagating the signal and then
back propagating the loss through the
individual to the individual functions
so I have to forward propagate and then
propagate back in order to get the loss
and that means I can only train with one
token at a time in the same time if I do
this in a Transformer I have a attention
mechanism on top so everything can
attend to everything else notably no
that's not correct if I have a GPT style
Transformer everything can attend to the
tokens in the back so you know that
causal mask and that causal mask causes
causes a property where I can train with
all the tokens at once I can train with
this token because due to the causal
mask it can only see backwards I can
train with this token because do to the
causal mask it can only see backwards so
I can essentially use the then every
single token becomes a training example
and yeah so that's training parallelism
if we look at
a equation
ax
plus b y plus z z equals something
funny funny face uh Little Triangle no
let's make this into
a little kitty cat so little kitty cat
that's a word look at okay
um if we look at this equation this is a
completely linear equation in its
components right so what we're trying to
explore is how can we make this into a
recurrent Network and how can we make
this into a parallel Network so how can
we compute this in a recurrent fashion
but also in a parallel fashion and
you'll see that what essentially retnet
does does this by making everything
linear uh
inside of that layer we can do it
recurrently or in parallel so how do we
do this how do we compute little kitty
cat recurrently well we compute ax we
store it into a buffer let's call that
buffer gamma
then we compute b y we add gamma and we
store that into the buffer and then we
compute ZZ we add the previous buffer
and we store that into a buffer at which
point that buffer is going to equal
what we want okay so this is a recurrent
computation reusing this buffer right
here
storing things in the buffer step by
step accumulating over time so a
recurrent neural network just
step-by-step accumulates
if you look at how usually how this
looks in as an equation in a no
if we look at like a true recur neural
network we obviously have
non-linearities in between so it would
be something like I don't know if ax and
then some non-linearity and then plus b
y and then some non-linearity and so on
right
this unless I have some knowledge about
this non-linearity right here that
allows me to do some tricks it
necessitates that I compute this thing
here first and then this thing and then
the outer thing so I have to compute
step by step that's why I can't
parallelize recurrent neural networks
because I always need to do the inner
computation first before I go to the
next time step by the way that's the
same reason that's the same neural
networks in the num in themselves kind
of look like this so they have layer
layer layer and I need to go up the
layers before I can back propagate back
down there's no way for me to compute
all the layers at the same time I need
the output of the last layer to compute
the next layer a recurrent neural
network is nothing else but just that
turned on its side essentially and not
in layers but in time steps so I need to
go over the time steps and I need to
back propagate so I can't just train
everything at the same time
I mean I can but I need to compute the
gradients backwards in time and yeah
yeah
I hope it's it's evident what I mean so
let's look at how we can write this
equation here in a parallel fashion so
in a parallel fashion I would just do
something like well I have a b c as a
vector and I make a DOT product with x y
z
and that will be
a little kitty cat
sorry I don't know what's wrong with
this pen here
you can see that in this manner in this
manner I just have a uh adult product
everything is computed at the same time
so I do all of these multiplications and
then at the end I do a sum and that
gives me little kitty cat as at once
okay so this is Computing it in a
parallel fashion
you can see the same equation once
recurrently once parallel now let's look
at fully parallel architectures such as
the Transformer why can't they be
written recurrently so in a recurrent
fashion I have the advantage that my
memory requirement is only this buffer
right here I just accumulate into the
buffer whereas here my memory
requirement is essentially holding all
the dot products and then aggregating
them together so why can a Transformer
not be written recurrently well that's
because it has the softmax operation
notably so if I have a soft Max
something like e
a X Plus e b y plus e z z divided by the
normalization factor like log sum XBR I
need to have all of these things
ready in order to compute I have to
compute each of them I have to hold them
and then I have to uh aggregate them
together and this is only over the soft
Max obviously how many terms do I have
here usually I have to compute the
attention Matrix and the attention
Matrix of all of these dot products is
quadratic but nonetheless I I have
because of this non-linearity because of
the softbox and how it Aggregates is not
possible for me to compute this in a
recurrent fashion at least not without a
lot of trade-offs in other dimension so
the softmax is one of the reasons why
Transformers can't be written
recurrently so what do these models do
they just leave away the soft Max by
leaving away the soft Max they just kind
of make everything linear and make
everything able to be written in a
recurrent fashion and more than that by
making it like linear they are now can
claim well we're at the same time we're
a recurrent Network and we're a parallel
Network we can be written in either way
that's cool and all but you're trading
off sort of representation power and
that's the entire question of
experimental evaluation
so here they derive retention
so just to say this isn't retention over
here what I've demonstrated it's just
the principle of if you have something
that's just linear you can write it in a
recurrent and in a parallel form right
and that is very advantageous but the
trade-off is of course it's all linear
now and there is no like the the soft
Max as a powerful non-linearity in
between Falls away and therefore you
would expect something to change and so
the claim here is of this paper
experimentally that they show that it
doesn't hurt them in fact it seems to
help them if that's true then we would
have a
architecture that could scale fairly to
fairly High degree at least in inference
so you'd still need to train with the
quadratic and so on
um yeah right
so what do they do they go through a
long derivation here but ultimately
retention turns out to be like this so
it turns out to be a query times keys so
query
that's derived from
X so from the data sorry
um
having a bit of a blackout here you take
your data you multiply it by a learned
Matrix to get the queries don't worry
about this thing right here like this is
completely useless it there's its
complex conjugate cancels out as far as
I can tell just this complex eigenvalues
the other the derivation here goes via
like the the eigen the complex eigen
decomposition of some Matrix it just
like just turns out to be a scalar at
the end
so queries times Keys outer product as
we are used to from standard
Transformers
multiplied by D which is the causal mask
the causal mask usually is sort of a
triangular Matrix that just prevents a
token from sort of looking ahead into
the future this is a hack and this is
what allows Transformers in GPT style to
be trained in parallel so for every
token to become a training example
um the D is more than just the causal
mask it also has a Time Decay as you can
see right here gamma is a scalar and
that scalar is zero that's the causal
masking aspect and that scalar decays as
you look back further into time so this
is kind of a position in coding which is
directly encoded into the retention
mechanism so the further back in time a
token that you attend to is the more its
effect or its signal decays in that
causal mask and they're going to use
that later to do something pretty
interesting which is multi-scale
retention as they call it
and then they just multiply it by the
values so modulo modulo the causal mask
right here which also includes the
position encodings this is just queries
times Keys transposed right the outer
product times values
and you'll notice that crucially the
soft Max that would be here
is missing from the Transformer so
that's that's essentially the difference
it's it's Transformer attention without
the soft Max with the time Decay working
backwards and
here as I said you still have that
quadratic attention Matrix but given
that everything's linear you can now
write this in a recurrent fashion which
they do down here
you can write this in a recurrent
fashion so you can go over your sequence
and just accumulate it into a buffer and
um
and then compute that at least at
inference time run without the quadratic
memory bottleneck at training time if
you want to train in parallel you'll
still have that bottleneck although
given that it's linear you can probably
optimize a lot more stuff and trade off
a lot more stuff they also have diagrams
right here so you can see
um these just get multiplied together
whereas here you have that recurrent
State you scale it by that weighting
factor and then once you have that done
you can multiply multiply keys and
values this operation right here is the
one that would not be possible in a
Transformer right because you would have
to combine these apply the softmax
non-linearity over all the sequence and
then multiply by the values but because
it's linear we have the
commutativity property the associativity
property one of the properties that you
learn in like second grade that allows
us to sort of change the order of
operations uh and do this multiplication
here first and only at the end multiply
by the query so you can see the hidden
state is carried forward without ever
having been multiplied by the queries
and you only need to multiply by the
queries in sort of the step where it
happens and then the next step you
multiply by the next queries only having
accumulated keys and values which makes
sense right every token
produces its queries and then looks at
sort of the entire past sequence on the
keys key value multiplication again not
possible if we actually had that soft
Max
so that's that's that they also have a
chunk wise recurrent representation so
chunk wise essentially just means hey
let's just accumulate into this R buffer
which is a chunk so this all becomes
recursive
they mix the recurrent form the
recurrent form being let's accumulate
into a buffer and the parallel form into
saying let's accumulate like the past
the distant past into a buffer and for
the current Chunk we do the parallel
parallel mode in that they can so this
is a trade-off between recurrent and
parallel
and that allows them to scale to really
long sequences because they essentially
accumulate into a buffer for very very
past sequences let's say
this is something that they can now do
gated multi-scale attention which I find
pretty interesting is a pretty it's a
easy I would guess extension but very
interesting because they have the time
decay in the position encodings in the
causal mask they can say hey usually you
have this multi-head attention right so
in attention you don't just have uh
queries Keys even in the regular
attention times values but you kind of
split them up so you produce sort of
query one times key one
uh times value one sorry value one let's
just call them so you produce all of
these different things you you produce
them and you split them up
so when you go from your data to your
queries your queries is a big vector and
you're just going to split them up like
into four parts let's say and these all
go into their separate attention
mechanism before being combined at the
end it's called multi-head multi-head
attention
and it usually helps because the
different heads can care about different
things they say well if we do have
different heads if we do have different
computations can we make them different
so can't we apply a different gamma
sorry a different time Decay Factor two
comma 1 comma two gamma three so the
causal mask we apply but the decay of
values so it's not ones and zeros it's
actually gamma to some factor and zeros
and that gamma can change from head to
head so we can already pre-specify that
one head looks more or is more attentive
to very recent tokens and other heads
may be more lenient and maybe more
looking at the whole sequence
so the retention network is just stacked
layers of multi-scale retention and feed
forward networks token wise feed forward
networks each time adding a residual
connection right here and layer Norm in
between
so this is just like a Transformer
essentially I just replace multi-head
attention by multi-scale retention and
retention again
very similar to attention except leaving
away that soft Max and adding the time
Decay into the causal mask at least as
far as I can see
here they have architectural comparisons
compared to the Transformer which does
have training parallelization the
retention also has that
compared to the Transformer which has o
of an inference cost so memory goes up
with inference the
the retention does not have that no
sorry that's just inference cost how
much it costs me to run inference on an
additional token with the Transformer
you would have to Cache your keys and
value so there are these KV caches that
are now popular in Transformer inference
framework but you have to essentially
hold all of those things in memory as
you do inference so this is not about
the quadratic memory complexity right
here which is it's separate separate
column here as you can see rednet has o
of n
while uh Transformer has o of N squared
in any case you have to hold all of the
KV values in the Transformer as your
sequence goes longer whereas in red net
you can simply accumulate into a buffer
and then just keep that around for the
next token
so that's because it's being be able to
written in this recurrent fashion
performance here check mark check mark
and here again check mark check mark
um that's again an experimental claim
notably the comparison to
rwkv which has all of the same
properties well they say it's not as
performant but does not have training
parallelization in the text they say
that it runs recurrently for training
and for inference now I recall rwkv also
has a parallel formulation because
exactly the same thing it is being able
to be written in parallel in and in a
recurrent fashion now maybe they just
don't do it sorry my setup here keeps
spazzing out so I'm just gonna just
gonna finish very quickly before it
spouses out again
retinet scales better experimentally so
this is language model validation
perplexity this isn't some contrived
task which makes me feel like these Val
these experiments are okay valid
although the number of tokens here is
not you know llama Stylo 2 trillion
tokens or whatnot and the model sizes
they are sizable but they're not the
biggest sizes we have so far so it's
it's interesting to see whether this
will keep scaling with model size and
also with token size very very
interesting but the first experiments
look promising but I I just like I feel
we're gonna find out that these numbers
right here where in all of these tasks
uh retina is better than Transformer
there's going to be some sort of
recognition of where this type of model
is good and where it's maybe not as good
because so far from these experiments it
looks like boom everything's absolutely
fantastic and I suspect because they
make everything linear uh not everything
is going to be absolutely fantastic if
it is it would be fantastic right if it
is we would have a scalable architecture
that would cost very little to run
inference on that we could do a lot of
optimization tricks because everything
is linear and that even performs better
but I think that's a bit out out uh
as I said the jury's yet out I just
wanted to discuss a little bit this
architecture Again by making everything
linear they gain a lot of stuff and I'm
Greening out again so that was it for me
I'll see you around